But in spite of their time
they lived in and everything.
But given the time they lived in,
they were even more exceptional,
and I think that they also had a large
amount of children to take care of
and to watch over,
and I tried to point out in the book
a little bit about how Mother,
and Dad too, very much,
sort of steered us in the
direction, and made it very clear
that we had a responsibility
being in America
to do something for our country.
That was very very clear.
And that was number one.
And I think it's a thing, you know,
because my brothers are so famous now,
and I think they were
certainly driven by that.
And Dad was a very loving
parent, but he was also strong.
When he said something,
you got the message.
- (laughs) You did it, right?
- (laughs) So I think that
they were unusual that way,
and they always kept us interested.
It wasn't a big labor of oh
dear, we have to do that again,
or something like that,
that's so difficult, you know.
It was always interesting.
The news is interesting.
Most of the time.
- Very interesting these days, Ambassador.
- I know. (laughs)
So I think the children, and they did,
we all enjoyed (mimics discussion).
Because we had different
opinions, and they always listened
to what Jack thinks we should
not go into the war either,
this is world war, but if he
goes, do we all have to serve?
Do we all have to serve?
Do girls and everyone
will get in the Army?
You know, all that sort of--
but it was all very interesting, you know.
And as the younger, as
the number eight of nine,
it was very interesting to listen
to these different opinions,
depending on the age,
and of course our older
brothers Joe and Jack,
particularly because they were the oldest,
were very interesting with
particularly my father.
You know, they could make
terrific conversation about
why are we holding back, and
why shouldn't we get in there,
you know, and making points.
And I think, you know, it
sticks with you forever,
if you get it at an early enough age.
So it made a huge impression
on me and all of us I think.
And I try and do a little
bit with my children as well.
- Well I was going to ask you that.
- Steve certainly did.
- Steve, did you feel that, did you feel
the same atmosphere in
your house growing up,
that the Ambassador just--